la parole est à Madame Jacqueline
farérol pour le groupe
UMP monsieur le Président chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Victorin Lurel ministre des
autres mères monsieur le ministre vous
avez eu l'occasion de souligner mardi
dernier à l'Assemblée nationale la
mobilisation des services de l'État à la
suite du passage du cyclone bégisa à la
Réunion la transmission y soir par la
préfecture au ministère de l'intérieur
et au ministère de l'outrem des demandes
de reconnaissance de l'État de
catastrophe naturelle formulé par les 24
communes de La Réunion vous permet
aujourd'hui d'agir vite lors de votre
visite samedi dernier à La Réunion qui
témoigne de votre réactivité pour
laquelle je tiens vraiment à vous
remercier très sincèrement vous avez pu
constater les conséquences désastreuse
de ce cyclone pour la population comme
pour tous les secteurs économiques
identifié comme prioritaire à la Réunion
par la loi de développement économique
de l'outrem le tourisme déjà fortement
impacté par la succession de différentes
crise les incendies du Maido les émeutes
du Chaudron la crise requin et bien sûr
la crise économique et bien ce tourisme
a de nouveau été aujourd'hui durement
touché avec le cyclone bégiza les
professionnels du tourisme ont subi des
pertes importantes au niveau des
infrastructures ce sont les boutiques et
les hôtels inondés ou partiellement
détruits même de même que les gites de
montagne 25 bateaux coulés près de 30 %
du parc nautique endommagés mais aussi
les plages et activités nautiques
complètement impraticables les J les
forêts les parcs animaliers vous avez vu
tout ça l'aquarium de Saint-Gilles et
les conservatoires botaniques qui ont
subi de dommages importants empêchant
leur réouverture au public évidemment ce
secteur est aujourd'hui sinistré
anéantissant les efforts financiers des
professionnels comme du conseil régional
depuis 3 ans alors que la haute saison
touristique court jusqu'en mars les
pertes d'exploitation subi nécessite que
la priorité soit donnée à la reprise des
activités il faut donc pour cela
financer les réparations et le
remplacement des équipements le matériel
endommagé il y a donc urgence à mettre
en place les dispositions de
catastrophes naturelles et le fond de
secours sans quoi la reprise de
l'activité sur les mois futurs sera
durement compromise à l'heure où vous
travaillez monsieur le ministre à la
rédaction d'une loi compétitivité
outreemère à l'heure également où vous
participez aux Assises du tourisme pour
y défendre l'outreem pouvez-vous nous
indiquer les mesures spécifiques
envisagées en lien notamment avec le
ministère du tourisme afin de permettre
la reprise la plus rapide des activités
touristiques à l'île de la Réunion je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
Monsieur victorurel ministre des outres
mèes mesames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Jacqueline farerol
vous l'avez dit votre île l'île de la
Réunion a été durement frappée par
bgizard les 2 et to janvier dernier le
Premier ministre m'a immédiatement
dépêché
à la Réunion et j'ai pu constater des
visus les dégâts votre î est endommagé
et sinistré mais j'allais dire pas pas
abattu parce que vous êtes immédiatement
mobilisé et en moins de 6 jours les
dégâts causés sur les réseaux de potable
d'électricité les routes la téléphonie
presque tout a été réparé au moment où
je vous parle il reste très peu de
foyers qui ne sont pas raccordés au
réseau de potable ou à l'électricité
bien sûr les autres secteurs de
l'économie ont été frappés et vous le
savez nous avons à déplorer un mort une
personne âgée et 15 blessés donc deux
graves sur les secteurs de l'économie
l'agriculture est très sérieusement
endommagé mais très rapidement nous
allons pouvoir mobiliser le fond de
secours pour les biens non assurables
les collectivités les entreprises les
particuliers pour les autres dossier ce
qu'on appelle la post-crise il faudra un
peu plus de temps nous avions demandé au
maire de se mobiliser dis ils l'ont fait
et vous l'avez dit les 24 maires ont
transmis au préfet de région les
dossiers qui ont été immédiatement
transmis j'ai donc la faveur de vous
dire que ce dossier pourra être examiné
éventuellement l'état de catastrophe
naturelle pourra être déclaré le 15
janvier parce qu'il y a une commission
qui se réunit le 15 janvier si tentait
que les dossiers soi euh complets vous
avez évoqué euh l'agriculture il y a un
problème spécifique mais qui est vrai
aussi dans l'Hexagone lorsqu'il y a
calamité c'est euh le problème de du
réamorçage de la relance avant quel que
soit la célérité les diligences que l'on
fera il y a un temps où avant que les
aides ne ne soit là et et n'arrive
comment le faire il y a un faux gap un
fond de garantie pour l'agriculture et
la pêche l'État a déposer à la FD disons
ça comme ça simplement 10 millions pour
l'ensemble des autres maires et bien
bien on pourra mobiliser ces crédits les
banques pourront faire des prêts les
interprofessions les coopératives les
groupement de producteurs pourront faire
par exemple l'avance des intrants les
banques pourront faire des des prêts qui
seront garantis par ce fond de garantie
pour l'agriculture et la pêche vous avez
évoqué le tourisme on s'est
immédiatement mobilisé avec les services
des collectivités pour réparer notamment
les sentiers le tourisme vert les
sentiers de randonné notamment à
mafat et donc je finirai euh le tourisme
dès la semaine prochaine pourra
reprendre et si tant est qu'il faille
mobiliser à tout France avec lesquels
nous avons des convention nous ne
manquerons pas de le faire et comme ça
c'est fait ailleurs et bien des
campagnes de promotion pourront
permettre de répartir je rappelle
monsieur le Président si vous le PER la
compétence est décentralisée il faudra
mobilisation des collectivit